لذلك أنا هنا في مستشفى العال، وهو عبارة عن
منشأة تابعة لجمعية الهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني
تحمل علامة الهلال الأحمر بوضوح
على السطح، ومنذ ساعتين فقط
يمكنك أن ترى ورائي وكل ما حولي
تعرضت هذه المنطقة للقصف، وقُتل خمسة أشخاص
هنا بما في ذلك  طفل يبلغ من العمر 5 أيام
لا ينبغي أن يُقتل أي طفل في العالم، ناهيك عن طفل
واحد، المأوى تحت
شعار منظمة إنسانية،
يجب أن تنتهي هذه الحرب، يمكنك رؤية
الحفاضات خلفي مباشرةً، كانت هذه مساحة
يعيش فيها الأطفال، هذه مساحة حيث
كان الأطفال  على قيد الحياة، يمكنك أن ترى الدماء على الأرض،
يجب أن يشعر العالم
بالرعب الشديد، يجب أن يكون العالم
غاضبًا تمامًا، قُتل طفل هنا اليوم،
قُتل أربعة أشخاص آخرين هنا اليوم
في مكان ينبغي أن يكون آمنًا، ولكن
لا توجد مساحة آمنة في غزة و
يجب أن
يخجل العالم